hey youtubers is Charlie and my Game of
Thrones Season 4 countdown continues in
my dead character montage last week I
asked you guys to pick the next video I
would do and overwhelmingly you all
wanted to talk about winds of winter I
also have information on the first four
episodes of season 4 so I'm gonna talk
about that first real quick if you're
finding me for the first time that I'm
just doing a series of special videos
counting down to the season 4 premiere
be sure to subscribe to get everything
I'll also post a link to my playlist so
you can see all the other videos I've
already done so far feel free to write
any suggestions for future videos in the
comments so first things first let's
talk season 4 titles episode 1 is called
two swords episode two is called the
lion and the rose episode three is
called breaker of chains and episode
four is called Oathkeeper so what do all
those titles mean so this is where
things might get a little bit spoilery
so just turn down the volume for a
little bit if you don't want to know
anything the episode 1 titled two swords
is a reference to the melting down of
Ned Stark's two-handed Valyrian
greatsword ice into two smaller blades
we saw an image of this in the trailer
one of the blades is named widow's wail
and is given to Joffrey as a wedding
present and the other larger blade is
named Oathkeeper and has given to Jaime
until he later gives it to Brienne the
episode to title the line of the Rose is
all purple wedding I won't mention the
crazy spoiler here and try not to post
it in the comments but the wedding
ceremony and the wedding reception will
take up the entire episode this will be
one of the first major events this
season if you didn't see it the
showrunner said that there would be
multiple red wedding level climaxes this
season not just one so it looks like
episode 2 will be the first one of those
just a heads up though I am planning on
doing multiple videos for the purple
wedding because it is going to be
awesome
the episode three title breaker of
chains probably has a couple meanings
every title has multiple meanings but
the first ones that come to mind here
are
Tyrians chains after the last episode
and to Daenerys trying to break the
slaves chains in Mereen so one person is
getting thrown in Chains and another
group is coming out of Chains if you
remember in the trailer we saw Tyrion
marching to his tribunal in Chains and
we also saw Danny and her men at the
beginning of a battle the breaking of
those slaves chains though could come in
a different episode from this battle
that they showed in the trailer
like after she moves into the giant
pyramid also from the trailer it's also
possible that the breaker of chains
could imply that some maesters chain
could be broken but this seems like it's
mostly going to be a Dany Tyrion episode
the episode for title Oathkeeper is all
about that sword from episode 1 but it
also kind of informs Brants quests to
find Sansa who they think I've been
kidnapped
there have actually been some behind the
scenes pics from these scenes just look
at Podrick smoking I wonder where you
would buy cigarettes in Old Town so you
can turn the volume back up although the
spoilers are over but let's talk some
Windsor winter now they've actually been
releasing bits of chapters in george RR
martin reads from the book at public
events sometimes the new excerpts they
posted on his blog are an Aryan Martel
POV chapter and a single paragraph from
a separate Tyrion chapter it's totally
free to read so you should definitely
check it out
the Tyrion paragraph also has some
potential spoilers in it if you haven't
read Dance with Dragons so I won't read
it aloud here but I will post it on
Twitter and Tumblr you can find all my
social links in the description for that
but here is actually a full list of the
POV chapters and winds of winter
there's Arianne Martell which you can
read now seon Greyjoy which you could
also read right now Sansa Stark Arya
Stark Victarion Greyjoy Barristan Selmy
and then lastly there's Tyrion so like I
said I'll post links to those preview
chapters on Twitter and Tumblr also if
you want to talk about spoilers in the
comments and you don't wanna make
everyone crazy all you have to do is
type spoiler in your comment in my
system we'll hold it until I approve it
so be sure to subscribe to get the rest
of my countdown videos and send me
suggestions on which ones you want to
see me do next right now click here for
all my countdown videos and click here
to catch up on The Walking Dead thank
you so much for watching I'll see you
guys tonight
high fives
you